so you're already familiar with the
Pythagorean theorem a squared plus b
squared equals c squared right so that's
when you have a right triangle like so
and we know that this leg squared plus
this leg squared equals the hypotenuse
squared and the way that we normally
write it is like this a squared plus B
squared equals C squared
but what we're going to do now is we're
going to actually take that equation
we're going to flip it okay so we're
actually going to put the C on the left
it's going to make a lot easier to tell
whether the triangle is a right triangle
and obtuse triangle or an acute triangle
so put the longest side over here on the
left side and then we're gonna check is
it equal to a squared plus B squared
those are the two shorter sides or is it
greater than or is it less than now I
just want to show you if you look at
this triangle here
imagine if C was longer imagine that
getting longer what would it do to this
angle it would open it up wider making
this angle across from this opposite
side making this angle greater than 90
degrees
obtuse so we can see C squared is
greater than a squared plus B squared
obtuse right but imagine if all of a
sudden you compress this and you made it
shorter this angle is across from that
shorter side now is going to be smaller
it's going to be an acute triangle and
of course if it's a squared plus B
squared equals C squared then it's a
right triangle so let's take a look at
some examples I'll show you how this
works so say for example we have the
sides of a triangle four five six we're
going to take that longest side which is
six and we're going to test it we're
going to say is six squared
question mark four squared plus five
squared so we have 36 1625 add these
together we get 41 36 okay it looks like
36 the longest side right is less than
41 so that tells that this tells us that
this is going to be an acute triangle
okay so acute meaning less than 90
degrees okay now this one nine twelve
and fifteen again 15 is the longest side
we're testing it here as the hypotenuse
as a seaside so we're going to test it
out we've got 15 squared question mark 9
squared plus 12 squared
okay 15 squared is 225 8 9 squared is 81
12 squared is 144 this adds up to 225
225 so you can see they're equal so that
tells us that this is going to form
these three sides are going to form a
right triangle so we're just going to
write right triangle the last example 4
7 & 8 again we take that longest side 8
that's our C side we're going to test it
out is 8 squared greater than less than
or equal to 4 squared plus 7 squared
let's test that out this adds up to 65
you can see that 64 is less than 65 so
that tells you that this is going to be
like that it's going to be an acute
angle so this is going to be an acute
triangle